Kim Vandiver: “So, how do you take a picture
of a bullet going through an apple.
All high speed single shot pictures, have
one key ingredient, that has to happen and
that is the triggering.
How do you know when to set off the flash.
That's the trick in every high speed photograph.
The bullet is traveling along, it’s faster
than speed of sound, it has a shock wave that
goes like a V behind it.
Down here out of the picture, is a microphone.
When the shockwave hits the microphone, the
microphone trips the flash and you catch the
bullet at that position.
“
These photographs were taken by Harold Edgerton,
an inventor and electrical engineering professor
at MIT.
Doc, as he was known on campus, was looking
for a way to study the subtle dynamics of
air, fluids and engines.
Kim Vandiver: “Edgerton was studying large
electric motors. he used primitive strobe
devices to study the rotation...and he didn't
like what he had for equipment.
So, he started inventing his own.”
“It takes less than a second to smash an
electric lightbulb with a hammer.
The Edgerton camera shows what really happened
in less than a second.”
Kim Vandiver: “A synchronized stroboscope,
is something that repeats, and it repeats
at the same rate as the event that you're
watching.”
Edgerton demonstrated how his strobe works
in a short documentary film titled, Quick'n
a Wink.
Kim Vandiver: “If you can imagine a fan
blade rotating around.
If a flash goes off at exactly the same position
each time, to you it looks like it's stopped.
And, if you slightly change the flash rate,
the propellor will look like it's very slowly
moving.”
Jim Bales: “Edgerton could control the flashes
in a way his predecessors couldn't.
He could get brighter flashes that were lit
for a shorter period of time with more precise
timing on exactly when the strobe would go
off.
That technical capability coupled with his
extraordinary photographer's eye allowed him
to take the photos that became the icons for
the world.”
Kim Vandiver: “Doc's pictures, many of them,
just had this startle factor to it, because
they just had never been possible before.”
Jim Bales: “When you look at that beautiful
crown, that splash of the drop of milk, it
turns out it's telling us fluid dynamics that
to this day we still don't understand.
What seems to be happening is when the drop
hits, jets of liquid come squirting out in
the sides, but there's air resistance and
somehow that turns it up into the sheet.
And at that point you've exhausted my understanding
of fluid dynamics.”
With an electric current passing through a
tube filled with gas, Doc found new ways to
produce high intensity, short bursts of light
that could freeze time, and turn it into a
moment we could all witness.
Kim Vandiver: “He set about to make flash
photography so popular, that the demand would
force an industry response to start making
it, and he obviously succeeded.
The way he did it was to equip the sports
photographer's with flash equipment.
He took a picture of boxer Joe Louis knocking
out his opponent, just at the instant of impact,
and nobody had ever seen it a picture like
that before.
So, that's help put high speed photography,
and Doc Edgerton on the map.”
During World War II, Edgerton's techniques
caught the attention of the U.S. military,
who asked him to develop a giant strobe for
aerial reconnaissance missions.
After the War ended, the Atomic Energy Commission
wanted to leverage his techniques for another
special project: photographing nuclear weapon
tests.
Kim Vandiver: “What it takes to make a electronic
flash, turns out to require very much the
same kind of circuitry, as it takes to set
off a bomb.
Nuclear blasts put out a lot of radiation,
a lot of x-rays, and x-rays fog film.
So, that made it particularly difficult to
take a picture of a atomic bomb blast.
They invented a magneto optic shutter.
It was basically a piece of quartz, with a
magnetic field, and a magnetic field on quartz
changes, what's called a polarization.
So, you could change it very fast, so you
let the light through to take the picture,
and turn it back off again and stop the light
from coming in.
And, each one of these still cameras had one
of those, and each one opened it at a slightly
different time, so with 200 cameras you could
get a movie of 200 pictures, and it was called
the Rapatronic camera.”
The magnetic field shutter was so fast that
it could capture critical details of how a
bomb's fireball evolved over time.
It also revealed the mottling of the fireball,
which are those spots you see here inside
the explosion.
The camera became a valuable diagnostic tool
scientists could use to understand exactly
what happens during an atomic bomb detonation.
Edgerton helped scientists and engineers uncover
dynamics at the millisecond level, revealing
subtleties about the mechanics of nature & physics
that were just hiding in plain sight.
Jim Bales: “Edgerton to the best of my knowledge
always considered himself an engineer.
Not an artist, not a photographer.”
Kim Vandiver: “He was a person who had a
good sense of humor.
He liked people.
He was very encouraging, so if you walked
in and said, I've always wanted to try building
this kind of a circuit, he'd say, well, there's
a soldering iron and a work bench, what are
you waiting for.”
Edgerton is considered the father of modern
high speed photography, and his legacy lives
on in everything from slow-motion videos we
see on YouTube to the advanced imaging techniques
we see in labs trying to capture details at
the cellular level.
Jim Bales: “If you look at the high speed
world today, the technology is fundamentally
different from what Edgerton did.
He worked with high speed film cameras where
the film would be coming behind the lens and
you'd use a strobe light to freeze the motion,
or other techniques with film.
Today they have a high speed video camera
designed to capture megapixel images at thousands
or tens of thousands of frames a second.
While that technology is new, beyond that
the techniques are really the same.
There are strange and wonderful things happening
on time scales our eyes can't capture, and
that it's possible to capture them and take
it apart and dissect the motion and learn
something new, helping people see things that
they hadn't seen before.”
For more science documentaries, check out
this one right here.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.